[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça chante et ça danse c'est comme un
dimanche on va s'amuser plom plom plom
plom et sonne les cloches sonne pour la
noce ils sont
mariés maman se désole papa la console à
chacun son tout et vive la fille qui Fa
sa famille gagne
l'amour au désert on chante chacun sa
romance même
grandpa qui a fait la guerre làbas on et
qui noublie
pas par les gros mademis
Paris F
bergè promenade
caramel mais les
petits
mour comme ils sont loin de tout ça il
se
caresse des yeux du bout des
doigts quand nous aurons des millions
nous meublerons là mais son
comme celle du
patron petit
patapon les Bell servant qui roule des
hanches pass les
PL le
ma il a le cœur
chaud monsieur le VI cherche
uneèreis que trouve dans la
[Musique]
d'autre promen
cartits
amour comme ils sont loin loin de tout
ça il se
dévor des yeux du bout des
doigts nous ferons beaucoup d'enfant
plein partout et le premier
justement avant qu'il ne soit
longtemps petit
chelinan voilà qui s'éloigne avec sa
compagne il n'ont pas
Somé les célibataires et leurs
cavalières
[Musique]
làhaut le fenêtrre sécl la fête adieu
les
petitsandis que grandpère Noé dans la
bière continue sa
vie
warum
énorme
colossal
monumental
cathédrale
Paris
Paris li Paris
Baris
jour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]